forget about Hunter and the White House
cocaine there's another Scandal we need
to talk about
the bidens are terrible dog owners Joe's
German Shepherd Commander going on a
biting Rampage the big guys big dog
chowing down on Secret Service agents
biting or attacking them 10 times in
four months the Untamed Beast even
sending one to the hospital
the White House blaming it on stress
yeah
as you all know the White House complex
can be unique and very stressful and
that is something I'm sure you all can
understand so under DC Municipal rules
after a dog
quarantine for 10 days do you know if
Commander was quarantined for I I would
have to refer to USS but as usual with
the Biden White House something's not
adding up on Cujo so I spoke to a
celebrity dog trainer Tom Davis to find
out more you know bite one bite two bite
three Etc it's you know I don't know I I
think that the dog definitely needs
training the dog definitely needs to be
put into a different environment that
they you know the dog can't make
mistakes in because right now it's clear
that the dog is making a mistake after
mistake after mistake
so Dana Perino is a famous dog owner yes
you'd put the dog down
information request which is something
that you are very good at but the
Judicial Watch was tipped off too right
what's interesting is that the Secret
Service is so professional that they
didn't even leak anything about this
this is not just a little nip okay they
he has been actually biting sending
somebody to the hospital like four four
to seven times however many times I
think that at this point
he might be a good dog and they I know
that they love their dog but I think you
would find another home for the dog he's
not safe around the Secret Service
agents
um the other thing is I could imagine
the chief of staff Jeff zeins going into
the president and saying sir
is Commander or Hunter they both can't
stop take like which one's giving you
more trouble right now uh that's a tough
call Janine you look like you wanted to
say something no I mean it could be
Hunter that's aggravating the dog you
don't know
um look I've had 13 dogs and I've had
Doberman Pinschers I've had abbreviated
Flander and now I have these Standard
Poodles you learn to train a dog this is
not difficult your dog bites someone you
get a trainer you get someone to deal
with them other dogs have lived in the
White House they haven't freaked out
this dog is living with the bidens he's
flipping his lid I don't know what to
tell you uh Harold Ford Jr I've got
three dogs one of my my oldest dogs are
Jack Russell she's getting a little
nippier here in her 13th 14th and 15th
years uh but I would agree with
everybody around the table if the dog
can't be comfortable and if you can't
put the dog in a place where he where
she's here she's going to be happy you
got to figure out a place uh did it
because the dog can't be happy if the
dog is biting people like that and
certainly the people being bit are not
happy either I would imagine Greg what
kind of dog is that it's a German
Shepherd beautiful dog now we know who's
on coke uh we're stalking the White
House and Spilled Clinton no I thank God
[Laughter]
I think God that command for Commander
that Obama's not in the white house
because the biting would be in Reverse
oh because he ate dogs he wasn't into
fine dining he was into fine canines
call me Obama do my show
but imagine being dressed dog you know
your owner's trying to drink out of the
same Bowl it's just not right imagine
being a circus service agent you just
hid the cocaine yeah and now they're
getting bit by his dog it's not fair
exactly hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else